hey guys my name is Jess it is November
the 28 and you're watching games what
new but thanks for doing that toss up
lata horizon threes first expansion has
been revealed and it's set in the snow
possibly the most other Australian
environment ever the Blizzard mountain
our Don introduces new terrain
challenges new areas in extreme Alpine
settings like a frozen lake and a snow
park as well as race events that have
been designed with mountains in mind
Microsoft explained in an xbox wire post
that there will be more than 50 new
events and challenges as well as new
race types including hill climb descent
and blizzard there are also 28 new
achievements to earn and eight new
vehicles to try your hand at Blizzard
mountain is at on December 13 for Xbox
one and PC and it's included with the
$35 expansion past it can also be
purchased on its own although standalone
pricing has not yet been announced next
up no man's sky looks to be getting a
vehicle and it's about damn time because
that walking speed is the stuff of
nightmares no man escapes new update
includes data files that appear to
allude to the existence of a vehicle
which is yet to be included in the game
reddit user Egan's uncovered textures
and a model for what appears to be a
sort of buggy said user then imported
the data into the game and release the
video you're watching right now of the
schematics you go and have made the data
files available to download publicly and
use as a mod but it's worth noting the
contraption doesn't currently work as a
functioning vehicle finally Bioware have
had more to say about mass effect
Andromeda's multiplayer bio a explain to
Game Informer that the multiplayer is
related to the single player in several
ways for instance one of the currencies
you earn in multiplayer called mission
funds is connected to the rest of the
game Bioware have said they don't want
to force those who want a purely
single-player experience into the
multiplayer but that it may lead to a
more hands-on experience producer
Fabrice con Dominus explained you will
have possibilities to send teams to
complete kind of side missions or to do
it yourself in multiplayer as for the
gameplay he added the first thing
everyone will notice is how
make it is everything is more fluid
fast-paced there's a lot of action going
on the controls are also more responsive
card packs are also returning and they
can be purchased with real-world money
or currency and in games let me know
what you cared about down in that
comment section head to gamespot for our
final fantasy 15 review and I will see
you again tomorrow